A common use for loops is in programs that simulate some activity, such as
customers in a supermarket, cars on a road, particles in a physical system. And
in such simulations you want to have a degree of randomness, just to model how
the real world works. For example, some random time might elapse. Until the
next customer arrives, or the customer might buy a random number of articles.
So let me show you how to generate random numbers in Java. You construct an
object of the Random class. And then you can ask it to give you another
integer. You have to give it an upper limit, and you get an integer between
zero and n minus one. You can also generate a random floating point number, and
then you always get a number that's at least zero but less than one. Let me
show you the random number generator in blue jay. let's make an object by going
to the tools menu, use library class, and here in the class field we type in
java.util .random and hit the Enter key. Select this constructor and here we
have a random number generator. Let's ask it for next double, and we get .05
and change and that looks pretty random. Next time when we ask it we get a
different random number, .19 and so on. For integers we'll pick this method
over here. We asked for an upper bound and now get a number between zero and
999. In this case I get 781. When I do it again I get a different number. Of
course every once in awhile I might get the same number twice. It's random. Now
I'll let you play with this. We want to simulate a die and that we get random
numbers between one and six. Or actually we might as well model a die with an
arbitrary number of sides, and your job is to implement the cast method so that
every time that. It's called, it returns a different number between one and the
number of sides of the die. There's just a catch. You're going to have to call
the next int method, which naturally gives you numbers between zero and n minus
one. You want numbers from one to n and I'll leave it to you to figure out how
to change one to the other. Has the construction parameter for debugging it's
handy to give the random number generator what's called a seed. And as long as
you seed a generator with a particular value, then it gives always the same
stream of seemingly random numbers. Here we're using a fixed seed, so that you
and I get the same answers. And practical applications, people do all sorts of
things for a seeding, such as using the time of day. Or when true randomness is
desired, they actually have a white noise generator attached to their computer
and sample it, so go ahead and implement the cast method.